[Music]
thank you
welcome there is nothing more important
than getting oxygen into our lungs
that's where it gets transported into
the blood so all your cells tissues
glands and organs can stay healthy
but what's going on in the air with
these bacterias and virus and pollutants
and things that we're inhaling every day
from our everyday toxins from cleaning
our house
and a list goes on
we can develop breathing issues that can
affect the health and wealth of our
bodies and when it comes to cleaning up
our lungs as well as our respiratory
tract there's nothing like oregano
oregano has so many different healing
medicinal properties so if it's
allergies asthma or whatever harmful
organism that's attacking your body when
you're inhaling it it's affecting your
respiratory tract as your sinuses can
swell up and work its way all the way
down into the trachea as well as into
the lungs and there's nothing worse to
try to breathe and we start developing
all this mucus this heaviness in the
chest where we can't get that oxygen
into our lung region but oregano
contains compounds like Carver crawl and
terpenes that help cleanse those lungs
it will help reduce inflammation and
congestion in the lungs and helps
improve air flow and when pollen dust
mold chemicals fungus or even pathogens
make its way into our body
her body starts to secrete histamine and
that histamine causes excessive swelling
into our facial area behind the sinuses
into our throat as well as our lungs and
it will counteract the histamine that
your body's releasing and will help
reduce those reactions it will reduce
the fluid buildup and that swelling
during that allergy attack and make it a
natural histamine reducing compound when
it comes to that coughing reflex that
you just can't stop coughing
oregano Can Do Magic for you and it will
help you get a better night's sleep so
your body can continue to repair and
heal and there are several different
ways you could be getting your oregano
right here you have organic dry Leaf
oregano you could be putting this in
your Foods your pastas whatever you like
but this is still very healthy and
there's nothing like fresh organic
oregano the minerals of vitamins the
phytonutrients the enzymes
and you can eat this anytime put it in
your foods make your salads your soups
however you like and it's delicious
or you can actually bake this you can
dry it you can make it as a tea I would
recommend buy your teas is so much
easier
definitely use those t's it will make a
tremendous difference when it comes to
your breathing and your lungs as well
and I love oil of wild oregano this is
potent oil
this you can take one or two drops
drop it underneath your tongue
you make it a little Zing if it's too
strong put it in a glass of water drink
it down
or in another beverage
another great thing you can do is you
can take a couple drops of this
and put it over a Boiling Pot of water
or a steamer you can put a towel over
your head if you're over a Boiling Pot
of water be careful you don't burn
yourself when those Vapors come up with
that oil of oregano I will tell you it
will just take away those sinuses will
flush you out and as you breathe it in
we'll get to the lungs will help cleanse
your lungs as well it's quite powerful
and I believe that everyone should be
cleansing their lungs intermittently
because having clean lungs means better
oxygen that fulfills the cells tissues
glands and organs of our body
I hope you enjoyed this video please
share with your friends and family and
most important make it a great day
I'm Dr Alan Mandel